Estamos en el problema 48 dice, si "x" al cuadrado es sumado a "x", la suma es 42
¿Cuál de los siguientes podría ser un valor de "x"? Entonces lo que tenemos que hacer es plantear primero la ecuación que nos están diciendo,
tratar de resolverla y ver con cuál de estos valores coincide, digo también podríamos
tratar de sustituir
cada uno de estos valores para lo que nos dice el texto pero, vamos a hacer esto un poco más interesante.
Así que si tenemos que "x" al cuadrado es sumado a "x", entonces vamos a tener "x" al cuadrado, le sumamos
"x" esto debe ser igual a 42 y ya tenemos una ecuación planteada.
Pero vamos a llevarlo a la forma que siempre nos gusta tener, es decir una forma cuadrática igualada a 0.
Entonces podemos restar 42 de ambos lados y tenemos "x" cuadrada más "x" -42
debe ser igual a 0 y ahora si ya tenemos la forma que nos gusta para resolver.
Entonces una forma de resolverlo que creo que va a ser más qué buena, es tratar de
factorizar el lado izquierdo. Entonces tengo que buscar 2 números que multiplicados me den -42
y sumados me den 1 ¿Verdad? Aquí hay un 1 como coeficiente de la  "X".
Entonces tenemos que buscar los factores de 42, puede ser 2 por 21 pero bueno ahí no, no va a ser
que la suma nos de 1, y de hecho tenemos que ver que como aquí hay un menos
tenemos que multiplicar 2 números y para que nos de algo negativo uno debe ser positivo y uno negativo.
¿Ok? Y de hecho el positivo tiene que ser más grande para que al sumarlos me de aquí
positivo ¿Verdad? Por ejemplo en este caso a mí me parece que
7 y - 6 funciona, y 7 por -6 es -42 y 7
- 6 es 1, entonces funciona muy bien. Tenemos "x" más 7 que multiplica a "x"
-6 ¿Ok? Entonces 6 por 7, 42
y como aquí hay un signo menos, aquí va con menos y luego 7 si le sumamos - 6 nos da 1.
Entonces esta factorización fue buena y la igualamos a 0, y aquí viene el truco por que, si tenemos un producto de dos números
que nos da 0, entonces alguno de ellos tiene que ser 0 entonces puede ser que "x" más 7 es 0
o bien "x" - 6 es igual a 0, si "x" más 7 es igual a 0
"x" es igual a -7 y si "x" -6 es igual a 0 entonces sumamos 6 de ambos lados,
y nos queda "x" igual a 6, estas son mis dos respuestas.
Vemos que coincide una de ellas con la respuesta A.
Vámonos con el problema 49.
¿Qué cantidad se debe agregar en ambos lados de esta ecuación para
completar el cuadrado? ¿Ok? Entonces
lo que tenemos que hacer es agregar algo de este lado y del otro lado también para que se preserve la igualdad,
pero de tal suerte que del lado izquierdo yo pueda esto factorizarlo como, como un binomio al cuadrado.
Entonces recordemos que es un binomio al cuadrado.
"x" más un número al cuadrado es "x" cuadrada más
O bueno vamos a
desarrollarlo tenemos "x" más "a" que es multiplicado por sí mismo otra vez,
y esto si lo desarrollamos es "x" por "x" es "x" cuadrada, "x" por "a" es ax
"a" por "x" es otra ax y "a" por "a"
es "a" cuadrada ¿Muy bien? Entonces esto lo podemos agrupar y me queda "x" cuadrada ¿Cuántos ax tuve? Pues tuve 2 ax
más "a" cuadrada, entonces si lo comparamos con esto de acá arriba,
nosotros tenemos que sumar la "a" cuadrada, para lo cual necesitamos saber quién es "a".
Entonces para conocer "a" tenemos que identificar este -8 este - 8 con el 2a
entonces si 2 veces este número es -8,
quiere decir que este número es la mitad de - 8 y la mitad de - 8 es -4,
así que lo que tenemos que agregar de ambos lados es -4 al cuadrado, como está
determinado aquí.
Entonces lo que vamos a tener es "x" cuadrada -8x, dejamos un espacio y debe ser esto igual a 5.
Entonces ¿Qué es lo que sumamos? "A" cuadrada pero, "a" dijimos que era -4 y -4 al cuadrado es
16, entonces sumamos de ambos lados
16 y lo que me queda es lo siguiente "x" cuadrada -8 x más 16 es
"x" más "a" que en nuestro caso es -4 ,entonces tenemos "x" - 4.
No quería decir "a" quise decir -4 al cuadrado, esto debe ser igual a 16 más cinco que son 21.
Entonces que fue ¿Cuál es la respuesta? ¿Qué fue lo que tuvimos que agregar en ambos lados? Pues agregamos
16 y esa sería la respuesta. Uno podría por ejemplo tratar ya de resolver esto, sacar raíz cuadrada y
resolver la "x" pero ya no está en lo que nos pide el problema, así que vamos a saltarnos al siguiente problema.
Me dice cuáles son las soluciones de la ecuación cuadrática "x" cuadrada más 6 "x" igual a 16.
Entonces ¿Qué es lo que hacemos como siempre? Tenemos que pasarlo a mi forma
que que nos agrada, para resolver, esto es una cuadrática igual a 0, entonces
si restamos 16 de ambos lados, nos queda "x" cuadrada más 6
"x" -16 igual a 0, y otra buena opción creo yo que podemos hacer es
factorizar la expresión de la izquierda.
Entonces buscamos 2 números que multiplicados me den -16 y sumados 6. Entonces otra vez como lo que hay que multiplicar,
me queda con signo negativo,
lo que tenemos que tener es,
lo que hay que tener más bien es uno positivo y uno negativo y además como la suma es
positiva, pues el más grande debe tener el signo positivo.
Entonces uno podría por ejemplo intentar con 4 y 4
4 por -4 es -16 pero 4 más -4 es 0, entonces ese no funciona .
Por ejemplo 8 y -2
8 y -2 su producto es -16 y su suma 8 más -2 es
6 entonces funciona de maravilla, funciona de maravilla. Y entonces escribimos que esto es "x" más 8 por
"x" - 2 igual a 0.
Entonces nuevamente un producto que me da 0 quiere decir que algunos de los factores es 0.
Entonces "x" más 8 es cero, o bien
"x" -2 es 0, si esto pasa
restamos 8 de ambos lados y tenemos "x" igual a
- 8 y si esto pasa sumamos 2 de ambos lados, y me queda "x" es igual a 2.
Entonces las respuestas son 2 y -8 que se encuentran en la opción C.
Vamos muy bien, ahora vamos con el siguiente problema,
que dice, el 51,  Lourdes resolvió correctamente la ecuación "x" cuadrada más 4x igual a 6,
completando el cuadrado, entonces hay que completar el cuadrado.
¿Qué ecuación es parte de su solución? ¿Ok? Entonces hay que identificar alguna de estas
ecuaciones, que de hecho aquí deben llevar cuadrados, aquí deben llevar cuadrados.
¿Muy bien?
Y ver cuál de estas opciones
corresponde a la solución, que pudo haber dado Lourdes, así que copiamos esto que tenemos acá y tenemos "x" cuadrada más 4x,
que le sumamos algo ,va a ser igual a 6 y le vamos a tener que sumar de ambos lados lo mismo, y otra vez
necesitamos encontrar
el número que al elevarlo al cuadrado, bueno tenemos que encontrar un número aquí que al sumarlo nos da un
binomio al cuadrado desarrollado ¿Verdad? .
Entonces esto ya lo vimos acá arriba en el ejercicio anterior y se calcula
dividiendo a la mitad
este número que tenemos aquí, el 4 si lo dividimos entre 2 nos queda
2 y eso al elevarlo al cuadrado es lo que hay que sumar aquí.
Entonces  2 al cuadrado es 4 y si sumamos 4 de ambos lados lo que obtenemos es
"x" más 2 ¿Verdad? Que fue
el número que encontramos, es la raíz cuadrada de este o la mitad de éste,
y es "x" más 2 al cuadrado debe ser igual a 6 más 4 que es 10 y eso es nuestra opción B.
En la opción B entonces todo el detalle está en que podamos
dividir esto a la mitad y elevarlo al cuadrado, eso es lo que sumamos ¿Verdad? Y además
el número que queda aquí, es la mitad de este justo, justo lo que tuvimos que elevar al cuadrado para sumar de ambos lados.
Espero no sea muy confuso y creo que hay tiempo para uno más.
Dice Alfredo está resolviendo esta ecuación
factorizando, entonces qué expresión sería uno de sus factores. A mí se me ocurre viendo esta ecuación que todos los coeficientes
tienen, son múltiplos de 5, entonces podemos primero dividir entre 5 y ¿Qué nos queda? 10 entre 5 son 2
"x" cuadrada -25 entre 5 son 5x
15 entre 5 son 3 y esto me da igual a 0 ¿Ok? Entonces
aquí el problema es que tenemos un 2 acompañando al "x" cuadrada, entonces pues verás que realmente es
complicado pero, podríamos
plantear una posible solución. Digamos que tal que esto se factoriza de la forma 2x más "a" por "x" más b
¿Ok?
Y a lo mejor tú dirás bueno, y como se te ocurrió plantearlo de esta forma, y simplemente es de ver que aquí hay un 2x
cuadrada entonces es como 2x por "x" ¿Verdad?
Entonces bueno esta es mi propuesta y hay que encontrar quién sería "a" y quién sería "b". Entonces hay que desarrollar esto
2x por "x" es 2x cuadrada, 2x por "b" son 2 bx
a por "x" es ax y "a" por "b" simplemente es ab.
Muy bien entonces si agrupamos los, estos términos estos términos tenemos 2x cuadrada más
¿Qué es lo que multiplica a "x"? Pues sería 2b más "a" que multiplica ax más "a" por "b".
Entonces fíjense que ahora tenemos que encontrar 2 números que multiplicados me den 3
y que el doble del primero más el segundo me de - 5.
Esto es bastante más complicado que lo que ya habíamos tenido antes,
sin embargo no puede ser muy difícil, los factores de 3 solo hay hay poquitos ¿Verdad? Es un número primo
sólo tiene dos factores, y es 1 y 3, así que por ejemplo,
si ponemos menos, ¿Qué será?
Qué el producto debe ser de 2 números con el mismo signo,
entonces y además la suma está debe ser un número negativo, así que es -1 por -3 ¿Verdad?
Ahora cuál sería "b" y cuál sería "a", por ejemplo si "a" es -3
y "b" es -1, tenemos -2 -3, en -5 funciona, funciona muy bien, y entonces esto al final me queda
2x -3 que multiplica a "x"
- 1 ¿Verdad? El doble de "b" que es
éste es -2
y si le sumo "a" que es -3 es -5, y el producto de -1 con -3 es 3,
y esto debe ser,
bueno esto es igual a 0 pero, sólo nos preguntan cuál sería uno de los factores,
y aquí justamente uno de los factores es 2x -3 que coincide con nuestra respuesta D, entonces de hecho...
Bueno con esto basta aquí dijimos que "b" es igual a -1 y que "a" es igual a -3.
En realidad resolver este tipo de
ecuaciones ya resulta como todo un arte ¿Verdad? No hay una, no hay algo mecánico o algo que
una, un
método que uno sigue,
constantemente y que nos diga cómo resolver el problema, si no se requiere de mucha inteligencia, de mucha habilidad
pero, sobre todo de que agarres, te ensucies las manos y hagas muchos ejercicios para resolver esto.
Entonces ya se me acabó el tiempo nos vemos en el próximo vídeo.